Brandon the Builder founder of House
Stark razed Winterfell with Giants over
a thousand years ago or so nursemaids
tell all the children of the north the
children nod wide-eyed unaware of the
lessened forced on them that if even
Giants are made a stark so too should
they but like every other castle
Winterfell was built in pieces over
thousands of years the first men settled
there because of the hot springs that
bubbled through the ground the water in
the heat helped them survive the
northern winters and they built defenses
to keep it for themselves nobody raised
the castle all at once
probably nobody meant to raise a castle
at all in those days the Starks were not
the greatest house in the north and
Winterfell was not the greatest castle
Meriton was the oldest dating to the
first King and the Starks fought the
Barrow Kings for a thousand years
greywater watch was like the chronic men
themselves a strangest only marriage
subdued its Marsh Kings but the greatest
rival to Winterfell was always the
dreadfort and my ancestors the red kings
of house Bolton
if tales can be believed we fought from
the long night until the Andals came
because of us Winterfell raised its
first walls when we took and burnt the
castle anyway Winterfell Biltmore keeps
more walls more guard towers they
expanded the granaries and larders to
survive our sieges they tended the
godswood to win favor with the old gods
against us as the castle grew more
farmers and villagers flocked every
winter from across the North to huddle
under its walls raising the winter town
in the spring these villagers would find
themselves marching in the stark armies
to fight against us the greatness of
Winterfell is as much our doing as the
Starks but in the end neither its stone
walls nor its tall keeps and iron gates
could save Winterfell at its height it
could have lasted a year under heavy
siege but a handful of Ironborn seized
it in the night while its Lord the king
in the north was playing in the south my
dagger ended his reign and now house
Bolton holds the castle of
ancient enemies the direwolf no longer
flies from the battlements above me
no gods the doors and cornices of
Winterfell against me below me miles of
long dead Starks fade into darkness and
obscurity until even their faces are
lost some northerners whisper that they
wait for the day their house will rise
again they will wait forever